ja meine damen und herren herzlich
willkommen wieder bei wwm wer weiß mehr
heute zum thema hans sarpei und wir
haben niemand geringerem zu gast als ein
surfer sensationell wir haben weder
kosten noch mühen gescheut um ihn auch
als experten für diese show zu diesem
thema zu gewinnen und ich habe ich hier
drei
fragen
über sich sehr über dich und du musst
sie diese richtig beantworten das ist
natürlich das wird schwer ich hoffe dass
ich gut vorbereitet hier hab ich ja
lexikon zu hause
ich hoffe ich habe alles musste alles
einfach franken also wie hoch ist dein
marktwert bei
transfermarkt.de
hunderttausend euro
200.000 euro
300.000 euro wer die c- oder 400.000
euro die idee was ist ein transfer werde
10c 300.000 würdest du einloggen
300.000 ein kann yoga kann gar nicht
und das ist richtig
fantastisch
wusstest du führerhauses geschätzt ich
hab's gern was geahnt habe mich ja
vorbereitet ja ja genau
weiß man sowas immer oder ist das
weiß man nicht was bekommst du am
meisten wie immer von freunden auf
transfermarkt.de hat ein anderer
kulturen deine und warum der spieler
nicht angeschaut haben
du bist noch wurde viel her wie könnte
es ja zum fc wechseln sich zieht
wer weiß wer nicht soll du wirst auf
jeden fall eine bereicherung für die
mannschaft glaubt
so schlecht
sollte ich nicht ganz
kann ich nicht kann ich nicht mithalten
okay okay so passiv dass gerade erzählt
du hast leider nur zwei bundesliga tore
geschossen als abwehrspieler jetzt ist
die frage wann hast du
dein letztes bundesliga-tor geschossen
war es
2004 oder 2005
ich bin
c seit 2004 ist sie sich sicher
aber hallo
und jetzt wieder richtig hammer
wenn doch mal noch nicht einmal selber
dass das hier natürlich also das steht
natürlich gut dann die letzte
wichtige frage
wieviel fans
hat die facebook seite momentan am tag
ist in die wüste hans sarpei kann
bierflaschen mit seiner vorhaut öffnen
hat diese these
gesagt wir müssen uns noch mal auf der
zunge zergehen lassen dabei kann
bierflaschen mit seiner frau einen sind
es
7000 also rund noch nicht genau die b 8
1010 9000 oder glied
ich weiß dass nichts das weiß ich nicht
das musst du aber wissen dass diese
hätte habe ich habe ich mir angeschaut
aber
das war
das war es ziemlich am anfang des weges
ich würde jetzt ja sagen würde sah sein
hallo
ja
so ein mist swrc 9000 berufen die mille
verlorene diesem fenster gibt es
eigentlich von hans h aber das
wir müssen jetzt bei
900 oder 900 deswegen da kann man nicht
alles trotzdem er hat sich gewünscht
hatten sich wunderbar geschlagen sehr
guter kandidaten ganz fantastisch vielen
dank ich denke auch nicht schlecht hans
sarpei beim wer weiß mehr wenn er aber
sehen wollt wie jemand wirklich ablöst
und ich den absoluten lach flash bekomme
man sät wwm mit den außenseiter müsste
hier klicken wenn er sehen wollte und
auch nicht ganz schlecht ist alpa gun
der weiß nämlich eine menge über sich
aber hat auch einen kleinen wissenslücke
dann klickt er beim zweiten video kann
auch irgendwo unten also ansonsten ist
dann dran und unbedingt ein vornehmer
gedanken
lustig